décembre dernier le 5 autour de 5000
personnes dans les rues de fort de
france
quelques jours plus tard le 17 environ
4000 pour demain les centrales espère
otobre monte dans la capitale mais pas
que mobilisation à fort de france mais
également sur site ce parce que vraiment
il faut il faut vraiment comment notre
mécontentement en gênant finalement nous
sommes bien d'accord que ça ça et en
tube le fonctionnement des écoles et
établissements
néanmoins il faut que les gens nous
fassent confiance on sera fier c'est une
faut rattraper le rendez vous est fixé à
8 heures à la maison des syndicats où
les derniers tours de vis ont été donnés
ces dernières heures pour que la
manifestation soit une réussite
à l'appel de la cdmt du se-unsa de fo de
la fsu et de la cgt m
savoir c'est ma chronique un pion cyr
étiquetés par le patronat qui dit que la
politique à mâcon et là nous voulons que
cette politique qui dicte pas la
patinoire à retirer cette loi de richard
autres et simplement retiré pas
d'aménagement se retirer par safé les
travailleurs aux revenus plus de ce
point de s'entendre le goût de la
manifestation est attendue dans les rues
de fort de france avec un parcours qui
dépendra de la hauteur de la
mobilisation
certains sites en communes pourraient
voir leur accès empêcher et des
mouvements locaux ne sont pas à exclure